- You play a therapist
- I do.
- on Shrinking, a very
funny one.
- Thank you.
- So, tell us about the show.
- Thank you, Yeah, so I
play this character named
Gabby, on Shrinking, which is on Apple TV,
and she works with Jimmy,
played by Jason Segel
and Paul, who's our boss,
played by Harrison Ford.
And Jimmy, Jimmy's character is grieving
because his wife suddenly passed away.
And I, they brought me onto the show,
it's done by Bill Lawrence,
and Brett Goldstein of
like The Lasso crew,
and they brought me on the show 'cause
they wanted my character to really balance
out like, Harrison Ford's surliness,
and then Jason's just
doing the Jason thing.
- (laughing)
- So they really wanted they wanted her to
come in and balance everything out.
And you can see in that office
from that clip that she's
very bright and colorful
and bubbly and it's really
fun because I get to be
- [Kelly] Very funny.
- Yeah, it's fun to be like
this, like bubbly, you know,
millennial black lady,
like saying "panties"
to Harrison Ford.
- (laughing and clapping)
- Like that rules.
- I'm sure he's Heard
that before. (laughs)
(crowd laughs)
- And it is, I think he's
heard it as "panties",
but then there's like
the black part of it,
which is like, oh, growing up,
like I didn't know until I was older
that it's not pan-teez,
it's paneez like, it's like,
- Oh, I don't know, I'm
Southern, we say paneez.
- [Jessica] It's paneez, right?
Yeah, But a lot of women go "pahnteez".
- Oh.
(crowd laughing)
- Like "pahnteez", it's my "pahnteez".
Right, Seth?
- I call 'em my "pahnteez".
(all laughing)
- I just love that people say "pahnteez".
- [Jessica] It's "pahnteez".
- [Kelly] I say paneez, whatever.